il est 17 heures 40
on est à montparnasse ouais et ont pas
leur ai dit oui
prête pour aller sonner chez des
inconnus et recharger chez eux les
batteries de notre voiture électrique et
les nôtres enfin si le courant passe
aujourd'hui on veut tous aller plus vite
être efficace ne pas perdre de temps
alors cet été mathilde et moi avons
décidé non pas de perdre mais de prendre
le temps le temps de se demander si
l'électrique est une source de progrès
social et surtout écologique le temps de
zigzaguer sur les nationales de france
en touraine en alsace en champagne dans
les cévennes à la rencontre de la
communauté électrique
nous sommes aussi calé en mécanique qu
en physique quantique
mais pour nous la voiture est surtout
prétexte à comprendre ces pionniers qui
partage la vie de ralentir de rouler
plus propre de ne plus être spectateur
mais acteur du changement
ce périple est aussi l'occasion d'un
voyage tout terrain parce que quand on
débarque à l'improviste
eh bien il faut pas toujours compter sur
un lit à baldaquin à l'arrivée
auxonne les feux comme en colo
non